bonjour vous êtes bien chez la famille
price si vous voulez joindre à temps
cory thomas ou ryan laissé un message
après baby vous n'étiez pas obligé de
rester avec elle
est-ce qu'on se connaît elle a dit
qu'elle était tombée enceinte et ensuite
elle a perdu le bébé c'était pas vrai
elle a jamais été enceinte elle vous a
menti je t'aime tellement
est-ce que tu as simuler sa grossesse ce
que je fais aujourd'hui c'est à dire la
vérité
or une écoute moi ce n'est pas ce que tu
penses il ya autre chose en jeu je crois
qu'elle est à la maison on soeur comment
tu peux ne pas savoir où elle est toi tu
le sceptre
j'écoute je sais que vous deux ça
n'aille pas très fort depuis un certain
temps quoi tu sais peut-être un truc que
je sais pas
une chaussure la paresse et les api
secoué demande aussi des renforts
le trousseau de clés de votre femme a
été trouvé sous les yeux ça n'a
absolument aucun sens si elle se pointe
mystérieusement elle balance une pompe
sur la vie des gens pour les [ __ ] en
l'air et ensuite disparaît c'est une
blague ou quoi je peux pas papa soit au
courant de ça je veux que tu me
promettent d'arrêter ce business tout
fait qu'est-ce que vous avez ta mère et
toi à fourrer votre nez dans nos
affaires
maintenant vous savez que c'est une
menteuse personne ne voulait que ça
évolue comme ça comment va-t-on adorable
femme
nous n'avons donc plus rien à nous dire
il a dit qu'il fallait l'arrêter
mon dieu on a tous nos petits secrets
enfouis quelque part et courtois
[Musique]
une